c'est un choix personnel la mamie parce
que je suis brûlé
trois députés péquistes annoncent leur
départ de la vie politique
deux autres devraient bientôt les imiter
dans les dernières semaines
cet enthousiasme est moins présent en
fait depuis la confédération il ya bon
an mal an 13 % des députés en moyenne
qui choisissent de ne pas solliciter de
nouveau mandat
si on ajoute à cela les 24 % de députées
qui sont battus ça fait en sorte que
plus du tiers de la chambre qui se
renouvelle en moyenne chaque élection
c'est ça le renouvellement de la
politique mais il ne faut pas confondre
renouvellement et rajeunissement de
l'assemblée nationale ceux d'entre vous
qui avez fréquenté le parlement son
action c'est en 1976 que l'âge moyen des
députés a été le plus faible de toute
l'histoire à 42,2 en depuis les élus
sont de plus en plus vieux leur âge
moyen atteint 53,7 en 2012 les militants
des partis politiques sont beaucoup plus
vieux donc la bassin de recrutement et
pluvieux d'abord les jeunes votre - il
milite moins dans les partis politiques
traditionnels que leurs aînés
ça se reflète aussi
dans la présentation qu'on à l'assemblée
les nouveaux députés ne sont pas tous
particulièrement jeune
lors des dernières élections il y avait
en moyenne 50 ans le jour de leur
assermentation dans l'intérêt de la
société et du québec d'avoir plus de
femmes présentes au poste de commande de
notre société et renouveau ne veut pas
nécessairement dire plus de femmes
national en 2012 33% des élus étaient
des femmes une proportion qui est tombée
à 27 % lors des dernières élections en
c'est clair qu'il ya une difficulté plus
croissante surtout pour une régénération
concilier vie politique et vie familiale
donc ça c'est un enjeu qui se reflète
notamment aussi du côté des candidates
pour la première fois depuis les années
80 les baby boom 1 ne formeront plus la
majorité du corps électoral québécois
lors du scrutin d'octobre selon des
projections des chercheurs de
l'université laval
les baby boomers les x et les grecs vont
avoir le même poids électoral ce qui
pourrait entraîner des changements au
sein de la députation ici hugo lavallée
radio canada québec